chaque crise est différente et les
problèmes qu'on a aujourd'hui avec un
état de la technique seront différents
c'est demain avec le problème à régler
qui sera de toute évidence différents
alors on peut essayer d'anticiper et
proposer des outils sui generis à faire
évoluer en fonction finalement aussi
delà de la technique alors que ce soient
les développements en termes
d'intelligence artificielle pour pour
améliorer par exemple l'identification
dans le domaine de la santé des
personnes à risques a pour prévenir ces
problèmes là où par exemple
l'amélioration de deux techniques en
matière de blog shane pour améliorer la
décentralisation de l'identité numérique
est bien de protéger un petit peu plus
les personnes au niveau de leurs données
personnelles et leur redonner une vraie
kappa une vraie capacitation aussi
individuelle
voilà on a une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui qui est celui de la
proportionnalité d'ailleurs le rapport
l'evoke entre bien évidemment le respect
de la santé et ce qui est tout à fait
tout à fait normal de de privilégier
aujourd'hui eon condemi ses 7,7 données
maintenance elle doit être également
respectueux des libertés individuelles
or là en se calquant sur un modèle me
dire à la chinoise paraît qui est qui et
qui prit d'ailleurs en modèle par le
parler les rapporteurs du projet tombe
un peu un peu des nues avec un système
de 2 pour ceux qui ne respecteraient pas
aller les quarantaines ou les
obligations sanitaires avec des
sanctions tombent le crès leur passe
navigo en le crès leurs comptes
bancaires ont leur prélèverait des
amendes directement sur leur compte avec
avec un système bond de deux clips de la
cliff qui serait appelée à la rescousse
avant pour autoriser à priori ce type de
ce type de mesures ça me semble
extrêmement dangereux il est né le voilà
le j'aime pas trop parler de ce terme
est en fait complètement liberticide en
l'occurrence
[Musique]
normalement l'hébergement de données
personnelles de consommateurs citoyens
européens est censé être en europe
après effectivement il ya une mainmise
d'entreprises étrangères principalement
américaines qui est vont avoir aussi des
obligations vis-à-vis de l'état dans
lequel elles ont leur activité
principale leur siège social etc et donc
les états unis vont être en capacité
dans un certain nombre de cas de pouvoir
obtenir malgré cette obligation
d'hébergement dans un pays tiers des
informations qui pourraient les
intéresser pour telle ou telle règle
ensuite on peut tout à fait aussi est
envisagé que des structures publiques se
structure assez molle impossible
d'envisager des modalités un peu plus
décentralisée pour réaliser ça il ya des
alternatives à une
on va dire une démission au profil des
gaffes
on a été quand même assez défaillant par
rapport au respect des données
numériques dans le cas de la gestion de
la crise qu'ont les anticipe c'est très
bien mais il faut les anticipées de
manière correcte et certainement pas en
bridant les libertés individuelles en
tout cas ça ça me fait ça me fait
extrêmement peur on a un nombre
extrêmement limité d'opérateurs
techniquement fiable qui pourrait qu'ils
pourraient héberger tout tout tout ça
ce qui ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est
que j'entendais le terme de
décentralisation parce qu'effectivement
c'est ça qui me semble le plus garante
des dés de celle de ces données dans le
rapport sénatorial sur le croisic d'atom
on parle bien d'une centralisation à
tout crin donc c'est bien ça le problème
on vraiment centralisée faire exactement
la verte de ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
garantir la sécurité des données
utilisées sur la blogo chaîne pour être
extrêmement utile aussi pour garantir la
fiabilité est là et là de toute toute la
chaîne de sécurité
on a aujourd'hui les outils
technologiques il faut les utiliser et
pas mettre la charrue avant les boeufs
[Musique]
on a des outils justement qu'ils sont en
train de se dessiner à l'échelle
européenne une proposition de règlement
aucun sur l'intelligence artificielle
qui envisagent en fait la question sous
l'angle du niveau de risque les ia qui
altèrent le comportement humain est ce
qu'ils vont faire prendre à l'être
humain
une décision qu'il n'aurait pas pris
sans l'information dire qui altère son
comportement
celles là sont interdites ensuite il y a
des liens sectorielle dans des dans des
secteurs à haut risque le secteur de la
santé bien évidemment et à haut risque
et donc dans ce domaine là ce qui est
envisagé c'est d'abord une logique de
mise en conformité préalable à la mise
sur le marché
donc un petit peu comme pour les
médicaments on sait très proche ce qui
est proposé dans le règlement c'est un
équivalent de marquage ce est donc dans
ce contexte ben justement une assurance
qu'il utiliserait unia pour profiler ses
clients seraient interdites
je pense que ça c'est un bon axe pour
redonner des garanties aux citoyens
européens
le règlement de européen me semble tout
à fait équilibré et parfaitement
respectueux j'espère qu'il sera votée et
appliquée en l'état
c'est vrai que ça sera un peu compliqué
de pour pour le quidam moyen de savoir
si derrière
est ce qu'il y aura une véritable
transparence des de ses algorithmes et
qu'on saura exactement si lorsqu'on
s'adresse à une mutuelle d'assurances
on sait que l'on va être profiler par
rapport à par rapport à un cadre qui va
être oui ou non déterminée par rapport à
par rapport à une réglementation
qu'elles soient locales ou locales et
européennes ça il faudra le voir à la
luz âge aujourd'hui on ne le sait pas
aujourd'hui il ya une très grande
opacité par rapport par rapport à
l'utilisation des intelligences
artificielles et des algorithmes de kiki
qui existe qui existe déjà
on nous promet de l'open data on l'a pas
non plus vraiment en totalité donc voilà
il ya encore un grand ménage à faire